[Musique]
merci Isabelle forain de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu des haut ces
membr du groupe Union centriste
porte-parole du MoDem on va revenir sur
l'actualité avec vous et on commence
d'abord par cette recrue d'essens des
actes antisémites Gérald armanin a donné
le chiffre de plus de 1700 actes
antisémites recensés dans le pays depuis
le 7 octobre quelle réponse politique on
apporte après la marche de dimanche
est-ce que pour vous elle a été un
sursaut durable il faut en tout cas ce
qui est dramatique c'est l'importation
du conflit de toute façon dans notre
pays donc il y a tout un arsenal
juridique en dehors de la réponse
politique il y a déjà un arsenal
juridique qui existe j'ai travaillé
d'ailleurs en 2022 sur un rapport sur
les actes antireligieux qui a été remis
à Jean Castex à l'époque où on pointait
déjà ce problème du conflit et de
l'importation du conflit et on voyait
effectivement malheureusement les recrud
des sens d'actes antisémite quand il y
avait un conflit Isra en Israël
notamment comme c'est le cas
actuellement é clair voilà c'est c'est
c'est c'était pointé alors nous ce qu'on
a vu dans notre rapport et qui existe
actuellement est ce que fait le
ministère de l'Intérieur et maintenant
faut que ça suive avec le ministère de
la justice c'est l'arsenal juridique qui
existe les plaintes déjà le signalement
qui doivent être fait et ça c'est
important et ensuite la réponse qui
doivent être apporté le suivi des
victimes et également alors il y a il y
a tout un arsenal juridique qui est
renforcé en plus quand il y a une
atteinte auocculte euh mais il faut
effectivement toujours mieux protéger
les victimes c'est ce que fait he le
ministère de l'Intérieur actuellement
puisque il y a quand même énormément
d'enquêtes en cours et il y a déjà plus
d'une trentaine de condamnations mais
est-ce que ce que vous avez vu aussi
dans ce rapport c'est pas la la
difficulté pour les victimes de porter
plainte les hésitations qu'elles ont à
le faire tout fait tout à fait et c'est
ça l'objet essentiel de ce rapport c'est
euh de sensibiliser et les responsables
de culte et euh d'autre part les
victimes à aller faire cette démarche
pour toute pour tout problème et pour
toute atteinte notamment aux personnes
il faut encourager ces démarches parce
que plus on a euh connaissance des faits
mieux on peut y répondre c'était
vraiment le le souhait et puis également
dans ce rapport on a encouragé euh les
préfectures notamment euh également la
justice dans les territoires à se mettre
en rapport avec les cultes dans chaque
région pour mieux communiquer et pour
faire connaître également les mesures de
protection qui existaient en France elle
est suffisamment rendez-vous la justice
quand il y a des plaintes de ce type
écoutez la justice on lui a rapporté on
lui a apporté depuis 6 ans des moyens
énormes supplémentaires moi j'étais hier
encore à la cour d'appel de Dijon euh on
part de loin on part de loin dans le
rattrapage des des des moyens donc bah
ils nous disent que il faudrait toujours
en faire plus on fait plus pour répondre
mais pour ça il faut effectivement les
personnels il faut résorber tout le
stock des affaires qui n'ont pas été
traitées ou qui ne sont mal traité donc
là il y a il y a toujours besoin d'être
encore plus à l'écoute on développe
énormément de moyens il faut les faire
connaître aussi il faut les faire
connaître auprès des des victimes
l'autre sujet ce sont ces rencontres de
Saint- acte 2 Emmanuel Macron qui reçoit
aujourd'hui les chefs de parti il y aura
des absents Olivier fort le socialiste
l'insoumis manuel bpard et erriic cioti
pour les républicains qui explique entre
autes son absence par l'absence
d'Emmanuel Macron dimanche à la marche
contre l'antisémitisme c'est regrettable
pour vous l'absence moi je dis que les
absents ont toujours tort et quand un
président de la République surtout en
dans cette période de difficulté que
nous vivons de crise internationale et
et et européenne également je P c'est
pour ça que tous les autres quand même
il vont c'est que quand le chef de
l'État vous propose un échange est
toujours bon d'aller échanger après ce
qui compte c'est aussi de pouvoir
avancer mais je crois que mettre sur le
même plan la présence à une marche et la
son absence pour Eric cotti aujourd'hui
ça n'a absolument rien à voir c'est
c'est pas très honnête honnêtement enfin
franchement c'est une opportunité de
discussion après cha est libre d'y
apporter ses réponses mais il y a des
sujets le chef de l'État ouvre sa porte
à des discussions
transpartisanes qui à mon avis sont
intéressantes quand même pour notre pays
on va parler des des sujets mais un mot
puisque Eric sootti répond ce matin
Emmanuel Macron qui l' accusé de faute
politique lors qu'il a annoncé son
absence et ce matin dans une lettre
ouverte ioti fusti je cite l'obsession
du palabre sans lendemain d'Emmanuel
Macron et il accuse le chef de l'État je
le cite là encore en démultipliant les
initiatives extérieures au champ
institutionnel de nourrir la crise de la
démocratie qu'en dites-vous je RIC Sotil
est dans son rôle d'opposant voilà
euh je pense que sur le sujet de la
démocratie on en parlera on peut faire
il faut avancer il faut faire des choses
vous savez bien je suis membre du MoDem
et qu'on a un certain nombre de
propositions sur le sujet et que nous
sommes en attente donc que si c'est
l'occasion aujourd'hui encore d'en
parler il faut aller en parler et il
faut pas en parler que dans les médias
il faut aller en parler avec les
décideurs allez justement on va parler
du fond puisque parmi les points abordés
lors de ces rencontres de saint-em la
question du référendum sujet qui sera
également abordé en séance la semaine
prochaine ici au Sénat puisque les
socialistes ont déposé un texte dans
leur niche on voit tout ça avec audre
[Musique]
vetaz bonjour Audrey bonjour bonjourour
et Audrey la semaine prochaine à
l'occasion d'une de leurs niches
parlementaires les socialistes
présenteront ce sera le 22 novembre une
proposition de loi pour simplifier le
référendum d'initiative partagé oui
l'objectif c'est de le rendre réalisable
car depuis qu'il a été instauré en 2008
aucun Rif n'a pu être organisé tellement
les conditions de mise en œuvre sont
compliquées alors Yan chanrel sénateur
socialiste des Français de l'étranger s
emparé du sujet il propose plusieurs
pistes pour simplifier tout cela en
commençant par réduire le nombre de
signature nécessaire pour déclencher la
procédure pour l'instant il en faut 4,8
millions soit 10 % du corps électoral il
propose de ramener tout ça à 1 million
rien la proposition de loi propose aussi
de donner plus de pouvoir aux citoyens
oui faire en sorte que le référendum
d'initiative partagé soit plus partagé
justement pour l'instant l'initiative
vient des parlementaires elle pourrait
avec cette proposition venir des
citoyens charges à eux de récolter les
signatures une fois qu'ils les ont ils
vont voir les parlementaires pour
valider tout ça avec sans signature de
sénateurs et de députés et puis dernier
point les socialistes veulent étendre le
champ du référendum aux questions
fiscales pour l'instant le rip ne
concerne que l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics les réformes relatives à la
politique économique et sociale ou la
ratification d'un traité susceptible
d'influencer le fonctionnement des
institutions alors cette proposition de
loi elle vient de connaître une mauvaise
passe oui elle a été rejetée par la
commission des Lois du Sénat vous nous
expliquerez tout ça motif invoqué par le
rapporteur Philippe Bas les solutions
que de cette proposition envisage sont
pour certaines inabouties ou
contestables dans leur principes même
s'il soulligne que l'initiative
contribue utilement aux réflexions sur
le sujet il rappelle que le chantier
vous en avez parlé a déjà été amorcé par
le Président de la République et les
présidents des deux assemblées lors des
précédentes rencontres de Saint-Denis
pas question donc de faire doublon mais
les socialistes ça vous pas vaincu non
il y a encore les discussions en séance
le 22 novembre et puis le vote et ils
ont une carte à jouer en essayant de
mobiliser la majorité présidentielle la
c'est ils ont fait appel à vous pardon
Emmanuel Macron lui-même s'est
positionné en faveur d'une
simplification du Rip c'était en octobre
dernier devant le Conseil
constitutionnel écoutez cette procédure
utile est aujourd'hui excessivement
contrainte sa mise en œuvre doit être
plus simple et les seuils permettant son
usage comme peut-être ces procédures
devraient dèslors être revu le président
est notamment d'accord pour abaisser le
nombre de signatures à 100 million et
pour élargir le champ d'application du
Rip aux questions de société même s'il
insiste sur le fait que selon lui le rip
ne doit pas avoir pour effet d'abroger
une loi promulguée depuis moins de 5 ans
ni de porter sur le même objet qu'un
texte en cours d'examen au Parlement ou
pas encore promulgué alors question
est-ce que vous allez voter pour cette
proposition de loi le 22 novembre je
suis la commission des lois et on a
rejeté le texte la proposition
socialiste pour les raisons qu'a invoqué
Philippa le rapporteur sur le fait que
c'était inabouti et que c'était un peu
compliqué dans la dans la mise en œuvre
en tout cas je suis d'accord il faut à
mon avis travailler sérieusement ce
sujet on avait pensé en tout cas à
l'époque j'étais député travailler sur
cette question en 2018 lors de la
proposition de travail sur la réforme
des institutions effectivement toujours
pour ces raisons d'abaissement du seuil
alors là il il propose un million nous
on était pas sur ces chiffres je sais
plus exactement si on était pas sur un
et demi 2 millions enfin en tout cas
l'idée est intéressante moi je crois
quand même que c'est un sujet qui doit
être travaillé de façon un peu plus
entre guillemets par une par une par un
vrai projet de loi de réforme
institutionnelle peut-être plus large
que uniquement sur le référendum
d'initiative populaire il faut il faut
en tout cas sur ces questions je pense
il y a il y a un vrai sujet de de dém
démocratie il y a un vrai sujet
là-dessus les socialistes ont raison
mais on le partage nous aussi avec la
majorité présidentielle c'est qu'il y a
une appétence en tout cas il y a une
demande des citoyens de mieux participer
à la vie publique alors ça passe par un
référendum et peut-être effectivement
assouplir les les conditions en tout cas
c'est ce qu'a dit le rapporteur
également il a il a bien pointé que
c'était un sujet mais sur lequel il
faudrait prendre un peu de temps on en a
pris hein c'est c'est clair on en a
presque trop pris mais ça fait partie
des sujets que nous au modem on porte
depuis longtemps ce souhait d'avancer
sur ces questions de démocratie sur ces
questions de paroes des citoyens mais
dans un équilibre si vous voulez
parlementaire et citoyenneté
participation citoyenne on a fait déjà
pas mal de choses avec notamment la
convention citoyenne et les deux
conventions citoyenes qui ont permis
cette expression ça veut dire quoi
inabouti et contestable c'était quoi les
les points qui coinçaient dans dans la
je pense que la mise en œuvre était nous
semblé
effectivement pas pas très réaliste à ce
stade
l'élargissement des
sujets on peut pas le voter comme ça ce
à ce stade moi je suis pas d'accord sur
cet
élargissement sur les sujets fiscaux non
je crois qu'il y a un moment il faut se
mettre autour d'une table peut-être
réfléchir on avait eu l'idée le
président de la République dans son
dernier pro projet présidentiel avait
l'idée de réunir un certain nombre de
personnes pour réfléchir sur la réforme
des institutions et moi-même je fais
partie avec un certain nombre de de
d'amis parlementaires de de du défi
démocratique c'est c'est si vous voulez
AC ville leendere on on on on souhaite
toujours aller plus loin malheureusement
pour le moment nos propositions c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire sont pas
forcément ça elleaboutit pas et vous le
dites c'est depuis le premier qu' Canada
oui mais oui je le dis parce que je je
voterai pas pour autant une PPL de ce
type parce que c'est pas voilà c'est pas
un travail c'est un travail qui
nécessite un peu de temps mais il faut
s'y mettre maintenant est-ce que ça
permettrait pas d'envoyer un signal
justement non je pas envoyer le signal
c'est le débat pourquoi pas le débat il
participer donner notre avis c'est ce
qu'a fait le rapporteur et c'est pour ça
que moi j'étais tout à fait d'accord
avec la finalement la réponse mesurée
qu'il a faite alors pas d'élargissement
au sujets fiscaux le président de la
République propose un élargissement
notamment au thème de société est-ce que
vous êtes
favorable
je je je il a lancé cette
piste notamment ça ça permettrait de
mettre le débat migratoire et aussi le
débat sur la fine dedans il y a des
demandes sur ce sujet moi je sais pas si
la fin de vie enfin quand on interroge
les Français ils sont assez favorables à
des à des évolutions sur ce sujet euh le
débat migratoire je vous le dis
sincèrement au sein de la majorité
présidentielle vous le savez très bien
euh nous n'y sommes pas favorables et
pourtant Emmanuel Macron il ouvre le
champ du référendum pour que ce soit
possible je je pense
qu'il de mettre le sujet en débat avec
les partis politiques parce que c'est
les partis politiques qui sont chargés
aussi euh d'animer euh la vie politique
et la vie démocratique donc c'est un bon
débat à mettre après sur souz pas qu'il
aboutisse c'est ça ce débat vous ne
souhaitez pas qu'il aboutisse je ne sais
pas si euh il faut faire le référendum
c'est ça la question est-ce qu'il faut
le faire le référendum moi pour le
moment euh je suis réservée sur ce sujet
j'ai pas eu l'occasion on n'a pas eu
forcément l'occasion d'en débattre d'en
débattre encore au sein de nos instances
politiques respectives pour les
centristes mais euh comme d'ailleurs mes
amis et les partenaires de Renaissance
sont réservés sur ce sujet pour le
moment je crois qu'il y a une autre
façon de débattre de ces questions on
fait une loi notamment sur les questions
d'immigration on a une loi on aura un
débat cette loi prévoit et j'espère
qu'elle sera votée et qu'elle pourra
aboutir assez rapidement en CMP elle
prévoit notamment chaque année un débat
parlementaire je crois que c'est aussi
la question des parlementaires on va en
parler de la loi immigration mais sur le
référendum il y aura un débat au Sénat
le 12 décembre pu que les républicains
vont faire examiner leur proposition de
loi constitutionnelle sur le sujet ça
veut dire que le groupe centriste s
opposera pour l'instant nous
effectivement nous y sommes opposés donc
ils auront pas la
majorité
répon on va répondre sur on sera
peut-être pas opposé à l'ensemble des
sujets qu'il souhaitent aborder il y
aura une nuance c'est Philippe bonc qui
ser chargé de de répondre on va y
travailler on a commencé à travailler
sur le sujet mais en tout
cas nous sommes effectivement réservés
sur ce sujet vous le savez ça veut dire
que le sujet de l'immigration fracture
la la majorité sénatoriale mais ça on
l'a vu pendant le débat même si vous
avez trouvé un accord est-ce qu' va
aussi fracturer votre majorité la
majorité présidentielle lors du débat à
l'Assemblée je le souhaite pas je le
souhaite pas on a commencé nous à
travailler avec les députés démocrate
justement pour leur expliquer l'accord
que nous avions notamment trouvé sur cet
article 4 bis qui était à notre
initiative donner la main au préfet sur
cette circulaire de sur les métiers en
tension ça veut dire que le groupe modem
le votera le modem je le souhaite je
souhaite qu'il maintienne et qu'il
conserve l'article cabis après on a fait
évaloir les sujets sur lequels il
fallait évoluer la question de la me de
toute façon sera aussi exposée via un
rapport qui sera rendu début décembre
demandé par madame la Première ministre
donc si vous voulez sur tous ces sujets
il y a le temps de l'Assemblée nationale
il y a le temps de la discussion je
pense que nous nous sommes les
centristes capables de discuter
évidemment avec les députés qui sont à
la qui sont rapporteurs pour certains et
que moi je connais très bien qui sont
des gens mesurés qui savent faire un bon
travail parlementaire vous savez je je
suis pas sûr finalement que ça soit au
sein des sont triste et de la majorité
que les que les sujets soient le plus
difficile je pense que du côté des LR il
y a des questions qui se posent entre la
position des LR ici avec lequel on a pu
trouver un accord avec lequel on a pu
trouver un un un texte et aboutir sur un
texte et la position de certains d'entre
eux notamment du président du groupe qui
dit je veux détricoter le texte il
ferait bien quand même de discuter un
peu avec le président du groupe LR du
Sénat mais chez vous vous souhaitez que
que en tout cas vos députés après on
verra le reste de la majorité
présidentielle vote cet article 4 bis
sur les métiers en tension mais
reviennent quand même sur
laame en tout cas regarde ce qu'on a
voté nous on a expliqué ce qu'on avait
voté on a transformé laame on a réduit
le panier de soins
essentiellement je pense que le rapport
de Monsieur stéphanini monsieur Evin
permettra un éclairage supplémentaire en
tout cas il y a il y a une proposition
intéressante il faut quand même revoir à
mon avis le panier de soins après ame
Amu je pense moi je je vous dis les
députés j'ai été député j'ai été à la
commission des lois on regarde un texte
on l'étudie sûrement revoir la question
des allocations non contributives vous
savez des allocations versées parce
qu'on est passé de 6 mois en situation
régulière à 5 ans bon ça franchement
personnellement ça me convient pas il y
a d'autres sujets sur lequels on a fait
un très bon travail notamment les
protections pour permettre les
expulsions la levée des protections et
là on l'a fait valoir également euh le
travail de navette doit se faire moi ce
que je souhaite surtout c'est qu'on
puisse aboutir assez rapidement début
2024 à une commission mixte paritaire
conclusive et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
d'ors et déjà se parler
s'écouter se respecter vous le dites
aussi à Sacha Houlier ça bien sûr
c'était pas sachou c'était pas
respectueux son interview dans le Figaro
en plein examen du texte au Sénat si
vous voulez les les assemblées elles
font un travail qu'on soit à l'Assemblée
nationale ouou au Sénat on se respecte
on respecte notre travail il faut savoir
qu'on a
d'éminents juristes aussi à la
commission des Lois du Sénat et que
c'est une belle commission qui a fait un
travail sérieux que nous avons à nous un
rapporteur centriste Philippe boncarer
je l'ai déjà cité qui a fait un travail
depuis le mois de février extrêmement
consciencieux avec Madame Jourda on peut
pas euh renier comme ça le travail d'une
assemblée il faut l'enrichir l'améliorer
garder cet équilibre aussi qui a été
trouvé et se garder euh des propos
caricaturaux est-ce que vous pensez
qu'une CMP conclusive peut peut avoir
lieu parce que tout le monde a tracé ses
lignes rouges dans les oui c'est normal
mais après c'est le jeu politique moi je
le souhaite parce que il y a une vraie
attente des Français sur ce sujet il y a
une attente de fermeté des Français euh
ils ont raison il y a des choses qui ne
comprennent pas quand ce texte permet
notamment de réduire les délais de
recour pour devant les
différentes juridictions quand un
demandeur d'asile n'a pas le droit à
l'asile et ben écoutez il y a une
demande ça va dans le bon sens nous y
étions favorables il faut que sur chacun
des sujets les parlementaires soi
responsable parce qu'après si on n pas
de CMP conclusive ça nous amène très
très loin dans le temps et là l'attente
des Français sera déçu et on les
comprendra donc moi je dis travaillons
d'ors déjà sur un certain nombre de
sujets ensemble pour pouvoir aboutir
j'espère au début de l'année 2024 voilà
c'est notre souhait en tout cas les
centristes je pense qu'on fait preuve de
modération et d'équilibre dans ce débat
merci Audrey merci à tout à l'heure oui
on parlera de la décriée Cour de Justice
de la République ça sera à suivre dans
le club d'abord on voit l'actualité dans
nos régions Isabelle Floren on va aller
à sens du côté d'osser retrouverver
Mathieu Villerois de Galot bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous journaliste
liyonne républicaine et l'actualité
aujourd'hui dans Lyonne républicaine
c'est cette décision de la Commission
européenne de renouveler l'autorisation
du glyphosate pour 10 ans décision qui
fait pas l'unanimité Matthieu
oui bonjour Arian bonjour madame la
sénatrice effectivement nous avons fait
le choix de de revenir sur ce dossier
qui n'en finit pas de faire une une
polémique c'est vrai que c cet herbicide
controversé est le plus utilisé à ce
jour dans le monde et on voit bien que
tous les pays de l'Union européenne
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre sur
l'autorisation donc là ils ont fait le
choix de repartir pour 10 ans une
question toute simple madame la
sénatrice sur ces questions là qui sont
des questions finalement qui touche à
tout ce qui est politique en faveur de
l'environnement pourquoi est-ce qu'on y
arrive pas on a l'impression que le je
dirais la majorité de l'opinion public
en France est plutôt favorable à tout ce
qui est environnement mais dès que ça
passe par la moulinette politique et ben
ça devient éminemment compliqué voire ça
bloque
pourquoi alors c'est des sujets qui sont
le ministre Marc F que je connais bien a
été très clair cette semaine finalement
au Sénat quand la position de la France
ça a été l'abstention il a expliqué
pourquoi il y a des sujets il y a des et
et il y a des productions il y a sur
lequel on a pu avancer et euh c'est
dommage de pas avoir obtenu forcément
des substitutions à l'herbicide et puis
il y a malheureusement euh sur des
cultures un problème et il faut
maintenir je rappelle juste que la
France et euh est finalement beaucoup
plus en avance qu'un certain nombre de
ces pays européens et je rappelle
également que le Luxembourg qui avait
interdit l'utilisation du glyphosate est
revenu sur la cette interdiction parce
que le problème c'est d'avoir les
produits de substitution pour les
agriculteurs donc moi je crois que le
ministre a une position équilibrée il
faut au maximum avancer en recherche
notamment pour trouver avec les
producteurs les euh produits
substitution c'est compliqué moi vous
savez euh sur la question des
néonicotinoïdes je franchement j'ai j'ai
étais pas favorable j'étais député à
l'époque je m'étais expliqué avec lui et
j'avais une position parce que c'était
encore aussi un sujet de biodiversité
qui me touchait particulièrement mais là
sur le glyphosate ça fait 50 ans que les
les agriculteurs utilisent ce produit
c'est encore très compliqué de trouver
une solution de substitution euh les
scientifiques effectivement de part et
d'autre essaye d'avancer mais aussi
faisons les les choses dans l'ordre
ensemble avec l'ensemble des pays
européens moi ce que je constate c'est
qu'il y a très peu de pays pour le
moment il y en a même aucun en Europe
qui a trouvé toutes les solutions et
notamment les substitution donc on a je
pense eu la bonne démarche c'est-à-dire
de pousser quand on peut à utiliser
évidemment et et à supprimer le
glyphosate c'est déjà le cas sur les
espace public euh je rappelle que pour
juste remettre les choses à leur place
dans nos villes on nutilise plus depuis
longtemps ces ces herbicides auprès de
de nos populations hein qui sont en
contact donc toiville c'est zéro
glyphosate hein en tout cas depuis un
certain nombre d'années mais
effectivement pour
l'agriculture c'est encore une
utilisation évidemment très importante
et et souhaitée parce que il y a pas
cette substitution donc c'est un vrai en
jeu
européen sur lequel il faut pousser
toujours mais mais la recherche
effectivement avance lentement parce que
ce produit évidemment est très plébisité
il faut je pense aussi faire une
information aux citoyens plus importante
ce qu'a fait d'ailleurs l'excellent
journaliste Patrick Cohen sur ce sujet
récemment merci
Mathieu merci à vousè bonne journée la
Une de Lyonne républicaine glyphosate
disons de plus c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Mathieu d'avoir
été avec nous merci Isabelle Floren
merci à vous d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure